We're less than one week away from the first round of the French election
and here the top five candidates
First up we have incumbent president  Emmanuel Macron at 28%
though his lead has been steadily narrowing the past couple of weeks
and he warned in his first and only rally over the weekend
against a
Brexit-like upset in the election
In 2nd place
we have Marine Le Pen, famed and familiar right wing rival to Macron
who ended up facing him in the second round back in 2017
since then, Le Pen has softened her party’s image
hoping to gain more centre-right voters
and it appears to be working
as she creeps back up in the polls
In perhaps one of the most interesting developments in the race
left-wing runner Jean-Luc Mélenchon
leader of La France Insoumise or Unsubmissive France
has become the new leader of the left
propelled to 3rd place by his brand of radical socialism
with some environmentalism
faring particularly well with young voters.
At number 4 we have fiery polemicist
Eric Zemmour who has polarised the right wing as the newest outsider in the race
but lost significant ground this past month
with increasingly extremist rhetoric.
And at number 5 we have centre-right
Valerie Pécresse who has been steadily slipping since her February kick-off rally
was widely criticised as lacklustre and uninspiring
Follow for more updates on the French elections!